l'égérie on va passer à un autre piège
et franchement suis là encore est très
très fort c'est maxime gainey qui a été
piégé par michel meyer il lui a proposé
une fausse paparazzade les deux à la une
d'un journal people public closer en
train de faire un petit bisou ou plus si
affinités
il a proposé à maxime gagné à tous les
chroniqueurs mais regardez d'abord celle
de maxime gainey et maxime gainey on a
découvert dans cette émission autant
hatem ben arfa c'est un gars calme c'est
un tu as peur
[Musique]
gignac est photographe et qui m'a
proposé des intrus qui moi je trouve
sympa après à peu de voix si tu sois ça
ne mange pas j'organise à faire des
fausses paparazzades nerfs je trouve ça
intéressant pour nous on a tous à y
gagner quelque chose pas cent mille
balles tu vois dans mon cash voit dans
la rue moi j'achète de loin un petit
bisou volé et machin truc avec un truc à
la ville un petit bisou à acheter qui
parle dans la presse moi je suis en
venir à bout des red hat
il ya 5000 imagine tu fais un autre truc
ont tous augmenté les tarifs gens c'est
un truc à la con un hôtel en et de
machins mal qu'on un peu un toit l'un
des ténors ma chance à voir à poil par
poil en peignoir si tu dois accepter une
section crips 59e' la même affiche sur
ex-époux gérer c'est pour l'épaule et
une défaite épique où tu achèteras
l'argent j'ai reçu ce rachat doit avoir
comme comme je partais un mauvais film
tombe sur internet je dirais que j'ai
fait un truc en béton et en moi j'ai
tout ce qu'il faut c'est pas possible tu
me connais suffisamment tôt michèle torr
en effet on a fait des tournées juin
doit être la structure de france a dit
sa mère c'est comme ça que j'aurais
choisi pour savoir tu vas droit faut
parfois faire des cartes montrant qu'on
n'a pas été pas dans le rouge paris
comme ça après tu reviens dans trois
mois mais je trace mon sillon je veux le
tracé si dieu tu m'a dit tu m'as laissé
entendre non je lis c'est là peut-être
chaud pour le faire je te dis que je
suis pas un tricheur n'ont pas digéré
que des jo je dis seulement à temps et
que je suis à peu imposée s'est blessé
dans ces heurts
mais je suis un peu
la tnt hd voilà alors là ce sera
évidemment pas ça mais c'est pour voir
un peu visuellement brooklyn donc
j'espère tu fais les meilleures photos
que ça n'a rien à voir c'est pas nous
c'est un montage quand tu vas voir c'est
vraiment solide et si pour vous pointe
point c'est une sorte de pashmina met
d'accord
comment ça soit ces questions où il se
sent si cette image là dessus sur une
connerie comme ça tu préfère faire du
temps à oreille si tu préfère faire ça
avec une nana concassage qui se laisse
avec une nana et toi aussi tu veux pas
faire face avec une nana rond le fait
chacun de côté en revanche moi je peux
pas manger mais on s'habitue serait
capable de démonter un scénario où on
s'embrasse moi j'ai calé choses légères
ouais c'était bien aujourd'hui ce mr
tard sur image de bon gros plans
annoncés pas les gros plans ou pas ces
décisions
voici revient sur ces suggère tu veux
combien et sur le fait gratuite ça ça
n'est vrai que pour une chaîne gratuite
ça n'était pas htc pas d'argent sale n'y
a pas d'argent moi j'aimerais trouver un
peu punk de casser l'image de sa liste
qui plaît aux gens quoi j'avais bien
s'énonce qui les suivent puisque le rsa
leur sincérité
ça sert ouais mais ils veulent de
surpayer jean pierre simard attaques et
les gens sont si la leçon pour le bisou
pas pour le reste a pour le coup mais
mais pour le bisou je pense que c'est
jouable
pour le musée sam et 0,5 mille églises
ou minimisé mardi mille que trop c'est
trop et déjà dit ce que je veux dire tu
penses une seconde que je peux encore
accepter la moindre des choses que tu
proposes bisous celles chez sextape moi
tu me blesse c'est mon intégrité
ok zack stentz et il faut que je prenne
trop de m'énerver l'analyse je m'énerve
et il va fouetter les colères qui sont
celles que j'ai entendu ça fait mal
oui c'est ça oui c'est ça je le répète
ça va je pensais pas gagner
je suis ce qui serait capable de prendre
des photos bah ouais c'est marrant mais
je n'ai pas d'avis mais qu il faut
regarder les photos photos cette
annulation
c'est pour te montrer ce que ça donne je
vais rien faire je vais tout le monde
oui je te fasse plus que sympa comme
idée sur longues focales fait là bas il
touche la main d'un chantre comme ça tu
démens disons ce que tu veux tu peux
dire mais ça c'est un copain de mon
talent et je me mets dans une spirale
infernale négative
quelqu'un de confiance max narrator
confiance pas le bon tournant libéral de
confiance mais est-ce qu'un cataplasme
voilà oui malgré ces m'a pris en photo
avant que tu demande l'autorisation se
rappelle d'où certainement sa nomination
c'est quoi la victoire ça c'est pas
possible
ok d'accord c'est bien mais ce combat
est fait ou pas en vrai tu me dis qu'il
est à l'aise que pasa s'il regarde tu
payes pas des données franchement faut
pas plus à tiroirs dans les orties mais
dans les orties et je suis de l'école
bon c'est mort une fois pour toutes
faut respecter les gens six mois tu
trouves que je ne respecte pas les gens
pour oscar attention peinture est
respectée
mélanger le pied de l'intimité des gens
d'accord la jeunesse via les 128 il a
tout tué violé
il a fallu deux secondes deux photos et
à ses fils et aux finitions sont fournis
aux questions sans foi ni loi mais bon
ça va proposer de la boa
[Applaudissements]
ça peut nous l'acceptons pas n'ont ils
pas d'homme sympathique il va comme ça
je n ai quelques mois afin de faire tu
dégages
[Applaudissements]
à kigali exception j'ai été surpris
choqués par sa composition mais il était
bien sérieusement l'histoire moi je suis
à moi je ne fais pas de victimes